He and I had another client who could be
lucid in her dreams,
which is more common among women.
She could ask the damn characters what
they represented and they would tell
her.
It was like,
okay,
that was pretty weird.
And like a lot of the things they told
her were really helpful and they were
not things that she wanted to hear.
She,
she basically,
one of them told her she,
if she was going to live,
she'd have to go visit a slaughterhouse.
And the reason for that was because she
was raised as a little princess and
protected from horrible mother nature
until she hit puberty,
in which time she turned into an evil
villain because that's how the family
work.
Perfect child evil teenager overnight.
And then,
well that was hard on her and she wasn't
prepared because she thought the world
was princess world and she couldn't go
through a butcher store without having a
fit.
And no wonder,
you know,
like really Jesus,
it's no wonder,
but you do it.
But she couldn't.
So we used to go to butcher stores and
that would make her cry.
And,
and um,
she was a vegetarian that would make her
cry and it will be mon the cruelty of
the world.
And it's like,
yeah,
fair enough,
man,
those are bloody slabs of meat.
It's like,
I don't know why everyone isn't
screaming when they walked through the
butcher store,
but,
but you gotta get used to it band
because you can't live in the world
otherwise.
And so the dream character who was a
gypsy told her that she had to go visit
a slaughterhouse,
which seemed rather impractical.
And so I asked her if she could think of
anything else to do and she thought,
well,
why don't we go visit a funeral home
and,
and watch an embalming?
And I thought,
oh good,
that sounds,
that sounds like a fun way to spend a
day.
And so I phoned up a funeral parlor and
I said,
I declined.
It was terrified of death now.
And I was a therapist who was also a
little shaky on the concept myself.
And so they,
they had no problem with that.
They deal with death all the time,
which is really something to think
about,
right?
A human being can actually have an
occupation where they do nothing but
deal with death and they don't go stark
raving mad.
It's like,
what the hell is up with that?
It's like working in a palliative care
ward where your clients that you have a
relationship,
all they're going to do is die this
week,
next week,
the week after.
People do that.
It's like those people are tough man.
They're tough.
So anyways,
we went and watched this embalming,
which was,
I have a rather high level of disgust
sensitivity.
So it was a little on the rough side for
me.
But she sat there and first,
well she was not,
we were outside this little room.
She was not looking at that man no way.
And she'd kind of go like this and you
know,
that was pretty good.
And then she'd go like this and then she
go like this and then.
And she watched it and then she asked if
she could go in and she put on a glove
and she touched the body and she didn't
a fit.
She didn't have a panic attack and so
she walked away from their learning that
there was a hell of a lot more to her
than she thought there was and that she
could see things that she didn't think
she could see and live,
and after that she sort of had a
touchstone.
It's like,
well,
I'm kind of afraid of this.
Well,
is it as bad as going to see the
bombing?
No,
it's not that bad.
Well,
I guess I can do it.
It's like an initiation,
right?
She had an initiation and so did I.
You know,
and I learned a lot from doing that.
I learned that one of the things you
need to do if you're going to be a human
being is to prepare yourself to be
useful in the face of death.
And so when you have a parent that dies,
which shatters people's ideas,
often they can't even think about it.
If you can't even think about that,
man,
you've got some thinking to do because
you need to be able to at least think
about that because otherwise you're just
going to be a wasteland when it happens
and you never know.
You could even have a higher ambition.
Maybe you could even be useful when it
happens instead of being part of the
heap of destroyed people who also have
to be taken care of,
you know,
and that's brutal.
You have to be brutal to be useful in
the aftermath of your parents' death.
You know,
you don't get to crumble and fall apart
and no,
you have every reason to.
So you got to be kind of some tough
monster to manage that,
but you want to be useful in the face of
tragedy or do you want to be pathetic?
Well,
you make your choice.